move from a president on the verge of
being removed right wing Guillermo lasso
disbanded the Ecuador's Parliament and
called early elections stopping his
impeachment process and causing a
serious political crisis in the country
Ecuador needs a new political and social
pact to allow it to escape from the
serious political crisis the country is
in and which unfortunately is getting
worse day by day we need to move forward
to a solution that can give hope to
Ecuadorian families for a future of
well-being and stability
their position has accused lasso of
allowing a corrupt contract between a
state company and a private business to
go ahead although he denies the
allegations
security forces were deployed outside
the parliament hours before the
president's announcement the police and
anti-riot gear has been barricating all
the entrants to the country's Congress
since the early hours of Wednesday
they're not letting anyone in not even
lawmakers and as you can see on this
side instead there are all the employees
workers that work inside Congress that
also haven't been able to enter and have
been here some of them since 5 a.m in
the morning
never before used constitutional Clause
known as Mutual death the Clause allows
him to govern by the Korean till fresh
elections can be held a process that
could take up to six months
many in the country fear that the
decision made by a very unpopular
president could spark a return of
violent Mass protest that rocked the
country in 2022 over the cost of living
the head of Ecuador's military warned
that his forces will act firmly against
any violence
the decision of the president to
dissolve the national assemblies based
on article 148 of the Constitution it is
therefore subject to a constitutional
norm and must be fully and completely
respected Ecuador's main opposition
party said that while lasso's use of the
mutual debt Clause was illegal they
won't challenge it in court
the president knows he was going to lose
because we had the votes to remove him
so in a cowardly manner he preferred to
sign an unconstitutional degree yet we
believe this is an opportunity for the
people to elect a government that will
work for them
other parties did start a challenge in
the courts and the country's powerful
indigenous organization konaya said it
will mobilize against any decree by the
president they might reject leaving
Ecuador in a state of high political
tension and uncertainty
[Music]